An ArrayList collects objects. We call those objects the elements of the list.
Here's one way of thinking about an ArrayList. You can think of it as a
sequence of mailboxes. Here is how you get an element out of an ArrayList.
Remember that gallery was an ArrayList of pictures. The get method can get a
picture out of that collection. The argument of the get method is called an
index and as it happens in Java the index values start with zero. So the first
element is at position zero. The second element is at position one, the third
at position two and so on. The get method returns the elements stored at the
index position. In our case that's the initial element and we store that in
this variable. What if we wanted to get at the last element? Then we need to
know how many elements are stored in the ArrayList at this time. The size
method tells us that. So gallery.size is the number of elements that's
currently stored in this particular ArrayList. Since the first index is zero,
the last index is one less than the size. Look at over here. This list here has
length five and the last element has index four. Now once we have the last
index, we can again use the get method passing at the last index to get the
last element out of here. Here you've seen how to access elements individually.
More often than not, we actually want to access all of the elements in a loop.
So let's have a look at that. In order to work with every element in an
ArrayList, you want to call the get method for every valid index. That means
zero, one, two and so on up to the size minus one. So here's what we need to
put into our four loop. I starts at zero. It get incremented at every step and
we stay in the loop while i is less than the size of the ArrayList. So this is
the classic loop to traverse all of the elements in an ArrayList. I takes every
legal index value, for each i we get the element stored in the ArrayList and
then we do something with that element. You will get to try that right now. Go
ahead and write a loop that draws every picture in the gallery.